There's something odd about me. Whenever
breaking news hits my area of expertise,
Islam, the persecution of religious
minorities, etc., I usually have nothing
to say. Odd? No. Well, here's the thing.
It's not news. Not to me. It's the same
script I broke down 20 years ago and
have repeated ever since. Over and over
again. And yet, nothing changes ever.
Let me show you what I mean. Take Syria.
Over the past couple of weeks, the
country's Drews minority has been hit
with a wave of jihadist terror. Pure
religiously motivated slaughter that's
already left at least a thousand people
dead. Quite more, possibly. It started
when Sunni Betterawin tribes backed by
the Syrian military, no less, stormed
multiple Drews villages in Sueda
province. What followed? ISIS style
atrocities. Militants screaming Allahu
Akbar, torching homes with families
still inside. Drew's villagers beheaded,
their mutilated bodies left on display
in the town square. And yes, there's
video shared proudly on pro-regime
channels showing the attackers chanting
Quran verses to justify the slaughter of
nonsnis. Among the slain were many women
and children, some butchered, some shot,
some, like I said, burned alive, others
just executed on the spot. Drew's girls
were abducted, raped, dumped. One had
her tongue cut out in a Quran verse
scrolled in blood across her breasts.
And what were the Syrian regime's troops
doing? Standing by. Try again. They were
helping, providing air surveillance,
supplying ammunition, etc. Cheering it
on, too. Of course. Syria's so-called
reformist president, Ahmed al-Sharah,
yeah, the guy the West is now praising,
blamed the Drews for inciting unrest. In
other words, they had it coming straight
out of the jihadist playbook. Let's not
forget this fellow is a former al-Qaeda
member. He was al-Nusra. Now he's
wearing a suit and calling it
moderation. Consider the words of Drew's
spiritual leader Hecmmit Al-Hijra. After
characterizing what's happening to his
people as a jihadist war of
extermination, he said, quote, "They
come with tanks and prayer rugs. They
kill us in the name of their God, and
the world applauds them as moderates."
Let that sink in. And the Christians
also being targeted. One family already
slaughtered, a church set ablaze to say
nothing of the June suicide bombing of
another church in Damascus, which left
over 25 Christians dead.
Even so, where's the news? Where's the
surprise? After all, when you mix the
same ingredients over and over again,
what do you expect will happen? Take
Muslim fundamentalists, add a vulnerable
non-Muslim group, make sure the
jihadists are the dominant flavor, and
voila, jihad, genocide, always. Remember
what ISIS did to the Yazidis a decade
ago? Well, now it's the Drews. Different
group, same exact outcome. And here's
why. Neither the Drews nor the Yazidis
are considered people of the book. That
means no special status whatsoever. No
vimei protections, no jizzy attacks,
just one option. Convert or die or
worse, slavery, rape, total
annihilation. This is happening right
now. And yet here we are again. No
lessons learned. No progress made. Just
rinse and repeat and repeat and repeat.
But if it only stops with jihadists
acting like jihadists. The rock goes
deeper and much closer to home. Let's
talk about American leadership.
Republicans, Democrats, Reagan, Bush,
Clinton, Obama, you name it. They've
consistently backed jihadist movements
abroad while pretending to stand for
religious freedom and human rights.
Obama especially, and I've written about
it plenty. Donald Trump even called
Obama the quote founder of ISIS.
But here's the twist. Trump was one of
the first to ease sanctions and publicly
praise Ahmed al- Sharah, the same guy
currently orchestrating Drew's genocide.
Here's what Trump said about him. quote,
"He's a young, attractive guy. Tough
guy, strong past. Very strong past
fighter. He's got a real shot at holding
it together." Really? That's what we're
doing now. Or rather, again, gushing
over a literal terrorist in a suit. This
guy was al-Qaeda. Remember them? 9/11,
3,000 dead Americans. Now he's got
Western approval and a free hand to do
ISIS 2.0. And all this while the former
president Bashar al- Assad who for all
his flaws was a secularist who did not
persecute his own people based on their
religion got sanctioned to hell and back
by the US. And now Trump thinks that
Shara will give Syria a quote chance at
greatness.
So let me ask you if Obama founded ISIS
as Trump correctly stated, what is he
Trump the founder of? Is this all just a
coincidence? Is US leadership forever
blind? or is it something darker?
Honestly, I lean toward the darker
explanation. Clearly, there's a hidden
agenda here. Either way, the results are
always the same. The US meddles in the
Muslim world, jihadists come to power,
religious minorities get butchered, and
then eventually the jihadists attack the
US 9/11 style. So, no, this isn't news
to me. That is, it's not new. It's not
shocking. It's not surprising. It's
business as usual. Don't get me wrong,
I'm glad some outlets are reporting
what's happening to the Drews. I, too,
had posted disturbing images, videos,
and quotes over at X simply so people
know what's happening. But I'm done
pretending that we need more analysis,
you know, to figure it out and get it
right. The pattern is obvious. The
script never changes. And worst of all,
the way people consume these atrocities
has become rather voyeristic. Massacre
happens. People act shocked. Social
media floods with hashtags and slogans.
A day or two later, we move on to
whatever the media has next in store for
us to be shocked and angry over. And the
victims left to rot, forgotten, wash,
rinse, repeat forever. It's pathetic. So
that's why I refrain from participating
in these grotesque charades. That's also
why I've shifted more toward writing
about history. Because you know what?
History, real history, is often fresher
and more revealing than today's forever
headlines. because it exposes what we
were never taught, what we were never
meant to know. And it reminds us of
something else. There was a time when
men actually acted in the face of evil.
Not just tweeted about it, not just rung
their hands, not just feigned outrage
until the next distraction came along.
And maybe, just maybe, that's how we
break the cycle. Not through the news,
which is anything but new, but through
the truth, long buried, long feared, and
still unwelcome.
[Music]